you're working 12 hours a day yeah and
you don't get much of a life so like
people don't realize like you be careful
what you wish for cuz when you get on a
show like and you're you're you know one
of top one two or three on the call
sheet oh your life's done that's your
life that that becomes your life like
like you get and on the weekends you're
so tired but you're learning lines for
the next week so like you never really
have a day Perpetual stress isn't you're
not well I don't know I don't know
stress is just like you don't get to
live life because you
your life becomes that character in that
show and then and you have very few
moments for yourself you know what I
mean yeah but don't you think that if
you're constantly learning lines if you
have this responsibility if there's
always a pressure on you to look good to
be rested to perform to do you know it's
like imagine it to me it's like sex it's
like you you're we have to perform you
know you have to and if it doesn't work
then everybody's disappointed mhm and so
there is a stress that I feel like if
you're on a show for seven 10 years that
at least I did I always carry that I
have to be good I have to know my L I
have to always I'm hanging out with my
friends I'm like oh two days I film
there's pressure there's pressure you
know like you're always thinking like I
got to know my lines for Monday so if
you're doing something on Saturday like
you're never relaxing never really Rel
you don't relax till that series's over
yeah yeah maybe you maybe you you're
different you seem more laid-back than I
am like you you could deal with pressure
I I haven't done the show I mean I did a
show for seven years but I wasn't like
was it about the opposite of a doctor
there was some doctors and stuff and and
Hospital stuff but um but I I I wasn't
number one on the call sheet so like I
and it was more of an ensemble and it
was a half hour so we only filmed five
day episodes it was kind of it was
really lovely actually it was perfect
because like I went in and I had uh you
know Wonderful actors to work with
uh I really enjoyed working with them
and it was just enough where I had some
days off and like I could fly it shot in
New York so I could fly home on the
weekends um and see my kids so so it was
a good balance so I could see you know
uh if you were number one or two I did
do a series I was number one on and it
only went a year but and we did like 22
Episodes and and that's a lot cuz 10
months out of the year you're on set
like 12 hours a day it sounds like oh
boohoo us but like it's it's not
glamorous it's not it's not red carpet
it's definitely like I mean there people
taking care of you you know you're
hungry you need a Coke I can get you a
Coke and you know so so it's not like
that's cuz you don't have time to do it
you don't have time to do it yeah it's
it's basically that if you're like no
I'll get my own C no I'll get it no no
no go on set we need
set but uh yeah but I didn't have to do
that I didn't do that Series in
particular for seven and I and and even
though it would have been nice to get
like one more year out of that like I I
was careful after that to like choose
like I remember getting an offer for uh
a series and it shot it was 22 Episodes
and like uh and it was a straight offer
and it was wonderful when you get a
straight offer right yeah uh and but it
shot in Chicago and I thought okay I had
the same thing yeah and I thought okay
so I have kids and if I take this series
in Chicago I'm not going to see them for
10 months out of the Year cuz it's like
I'm number one on the call [__] I won't
be able to fly home on the weekends
right and uh and and and they're not
going to come to Chicago cuz my kids
were all in school in La so then like 10
months out of the year I was like I'm
not going to see them and then as an
actor you're like best case scenario
this goes 7 years so I won't see my
family for what seven years like like
and then they're going to be grown up
and I'll have a ton of money but I I
won't have had the time with them so
then it became like I said no and then
they came back with more money and then
I said no again and then agent was like
no no take the money and I was like I I
can't cuz like I they were like it's
they they they were throwing ridiculous
the more you say no that's like an apod
only if you mean it never say no if
you're trying to get something if you're
try to get something it doesn't work you
have to really like they smell it out
you know oh yeah like I don't want to do
it yeah well what's going to cost us
yeah nothing yeah and then and then it
came back with more and more and then I
was just like I can't and I didn't do it
and it lasted maybe that series uh only
lasted like five or six episodes got
canel so so honestly like I'm glad I
didn't do it cuz it would have been a
canceled series under your belt you
don't want to have too many canceled
series under your belt so like